washington tonight thank you and as newt
gingrich writes
in a brand new column foxnews.com quote
speaker pelosi's fence around the u.s
capitol is an
eyesore an insult to the american people
an
embarrassment for the united states
around the world here to explain more
fox news contributor former speaker of
the house newt gingrich
i actually might have a slight
disagreement with you
is we have to protect that's our house
that's the people's house
we have to protect our institutions
elected officials
this is not political both sides of the
aisle have to be protected they have to
be safe
we now know that there was intelligence
before
what happened on january 6th nobody
nobody prepared properly the guard was
called in
uh six separate times the president
offered the guard as well
um if this is a temporary fix i
i don't really have a problem with it
but sean what are you trying to
temporarily fix
there's no known threat to the u.s
capitol
there's no indication anywhere that
there's some
organized mob preparing to storm
washington
this is all a function of nancy pelosi's
paranoia
and the fact that the left wants
americans
to think that their government has to
protect them from some unknown
strange group the fact is you know when
i was speaking of the house we
modernized the
capitol police we brought in the chief
of staff to the secret service
we went through a very elaborate process
and produced a very professional
police force i think that with
reasonable leadership
they can protect the capital without all
these fences
without all of this barb this razor wire
i think it's an insult to every american
to be told that their politicians are so
important
that they're going to hide behind a wall
while the rest of us apparently are in
danger
that's the opposite of a free society
and i'm very worried
by the steady drift towards an
authoritarian
and at times the totalitarian government
and you see it at the state level
you see it in some of the big cities and
now you see it on your own national
capital
i think this is profoundly wrong and
that that wall should come down
immediately
until we know we have the plan in place
that if something happens that we have
the ability and the means to react in
record time and protect any
any effort that might be to tear down an
institution or
hurt our elected officials again this
would be a temporary solution
i find the fact that all these democrats
said the wall at the southern border was
an immorality
and high you know a wall for we but not
for thee
oh okay that that really works out
pretty well it's a little
ironic to hear democrats against walls
except they need
when it comes to protecting themselves
nancy pelosi lives in a big gated
community in
san francisco milton surrounded by
and i have no problem with her success
but
okay if it's good for you why why would
you say not use it at the southern
border
look i i was in the capitol when a
foreigner tried to set off a bomb uh
luckily it did not go off
uh they set it off later on in fort
belvoir and it would have taken out
about a third of the house chamber
there were people then who panicked and
said oh my god maybe we should never let
americans into the house chamber well as
you know
visitors normally can go and sit in the
gallery
uh thousands of people do it every year
uh we've had three or four other
incidents like that over the years
and the answer has been that freedom has
to take some risks
now if we're going to become a police
state and we're going to have our
politicians
use the police against all the rest of
us and we're going to have the
politicians hide
behind walls you have to ask yourself
why aren't the politicians
sort of asking themselves why are people
this angry
whether on the right or the left whether
it's antifa
or black lives matter or the people who
were there on january 6th
i think that this effort to somehow
magically
figure out we're going to have we're
going to create a police state
we're going to tell you when you can get
through the wall
probably make sure that you have to walk
through various detectors
maybe make you get a reservation a month
in advance i just think the whole thing
is
absolutely unnecessary and i think it's
insulting
to every american citizen we're we're
supposed to be a free country
we're supposed to be a free country
where the politicians serve us
we don't serve the politicians and what
you're seeing whether it's in new york
or california or illinois or nancy
pelosi's capital
is everything's being turned upside down
and everything joe biden's doing from
joining the climate accords
appeasement of iran a stroke of a pen
bypassing an entire branch of government
the legislative branch
getting rid of the energy sector in this
country open borders
it's all amnesty it's all happening
everything we warn people about
right and i think the democrats will pay
an
enormous cost for having been doing
things that are so destructive
and so unacceptable all right so my next
question is
donald trump's going to give this speech
at cpac on sunday
the media can't quit following donald
trump they'd like to they say they'd
like to
we know it's impossible he's going to
give a speech
um i would imagine that it might be
a little different than what people are
thinking and i have something in my mind
that i believe it will be
i i don't want to really give it away or
or tell people but
i don't think it's going to be what
people think your thoughts
well i hope i hope it's not what people
think he has a wonderful opportunity
here
to begin to rebrand himself
communicate the strengths of his
policies and do it in a way which is
positive
and appealing and a dramatic contrast
to the confusion that you alluded to
earlier that seems to be the biden
standpoint i also frankly he'll focus on
not 2024 every republican i'd be
focusing
on how do we make sure that mccarthy is
the
speaker of the house and that mcconnell
is the senate majority leader
let's get through 22. you have lots of
time to talk presidency
after 2022. mr speaker thank you for
being with us when we come back